let's uh let's jump to our first segment
the Daily Mail reports workers in full
hazmat suits berry rows of coffins in
Hart island mass grave as New York City
officials confirm coronavirus victims
will be buried there if their bodies
aren't claimed within two weeks after
death after death toll rises to four
thousand two hundred sixty so man this
is this is brutal yeah there's a few
things that need be pointed out because
I don't trust the city you think they're
lying okay
they're claiming these are contract
laborers all right I'm gonna give you
all the warning for those that are just
tuning in there's gonna be some images
that might not make you happy they're
not graphic or anything but there's
they're images of the mass graves and so
look I think this is newsworthy it's
important to talk about it is pretty
shocking yeah but my deepest survey's
condolences to those who've lost or lost
their lives their loved ones these are
people who haven't been claimed by
anybody so it's probably older people
homeless people I'm not showing this out
of a lack of sensitivity I'm showing it
because we need to have conversation
about what real life is like I didn't
think about the homeless in New York
there is and that's why they do this
normally mom so here you can see these
workers in in full PPE gear they're
stacking bodies this guy standing on the
grave on these coffins you know and you
can see that they're stacked two on top
of each other maybe even more at least
can't really see very well but and it
looks like used to this guy's like
standing you know like up to his shins
in the dirt that's being poured in yeah
these are mass graves man
now look New York City said these are
not prison laborers doing it
and it's and it's kind of insane they
had to do that in the first place I
don't believe them you know why check
this out this is from March 31st the
intercept Rikers Island prisoners are
being offered PPE and 6,000 hour to dig
masks raised $6 an hour that's BS man
you know it's hard labor yeah let me let
me just say these people who are begging
for a zombie apocalypse and like a
nightmare dystopia yeah look would it be
really cool they lived in the future
you're living and it did yeah you are
here you're locked in your house people
are getting arrested for going outside
they're spying on your cell phones
Google knows where you are you know
Google's tracking everyone's phone data
and publishing it publishing it not your
individual data but they're tracking
what everyone is doing and then
publishing the mass data like here's
what humans are doing so there's my
siblings and I tried this where you type
into Google we are with you
and it pulls up your location yeah if
you type if you type in something like
we are with you here or something like
that yeah we're here with you
yeah are here with you yeah some weird
thing like that what and it shows you
where you are yeah my sister goin
nothing of course is Google being Google
yep
that's what I use duck duck yep yep we
are we are living in a world where a
pandemic is sweeping the globe people
are being arrested when they go outside
people are being arrested for telling
jokes in some countries like in the UK
we've got being shot in other countries
for just breaking quarantine no that's
not true that's fake news Oh was it
totally fake news interesting yes so so
Clara could this one up yeah I was I was
gonna do a segment on this yeah everyone
so uh do tear day in the Philippines
said shoot him dead if they break
quarantine right and we're not true that
was true okay and then also the story
started going around saying man who
breaks quarantine is shot dead yeah
and so I'm like wow look there it is
there's the news I pull it up I'm like
let's talk about it and so then I start
you know I read a little bit and I'm
like man that's crazy guess what what
the story really was a few paragraphs
down well well the guy was drunk and so
a site that people oh yeah they didn't
shoot him for breaking quarantine they
shot a drunk man swinging a site that
civilians Oh crazy it's a crazy story
it's crazy but it's not it's not I'm not
breaking quarantine yeah no he's
actually a threat to society but this
you know you know it's really scary you
know it proves when the dystopia well
that people don't think we're in one
that's a good point it's like they they
you have been coaxed into this nightmare
world well it feels like some people are
in this and some people aren't you know
I took a walk today and I saw other
people my neighbor hey what's up how you
doing walk past you know across the
street you know social distancing at all
but you know it likes to be normal you
know it didn't it there's a you know
that's why people were like is it real
is this really happening cuz I don't see
it I don't know anybody that's sick and
obviously it's really happening even
though you can't see it but it does feel
like there's still bubbles of people
that are life still kind of normal this
is how movies desensitize us yeah we're
so used to watching a movie
this constant action yeah like something
has to happen for you to know that okay
whoa now we're in the pandemic now it's
actually happening let me tell you buddy
when they started digging the mass
graves yeah and they started using
prison labor to do it that was a long
time ago we've been here for a minute so
what I guess people don't realize New
York what is it eight eight point six
million in the city yeah what do you
think most nine four hundred so it's a
hundred fifty 150 people die per day in
New York on average normally normally
okay right now it's way way up like it
was well like 750 the other day like
ridiculous because of kovat yeah but
what people don't realize this homeless
people like tens of thousands there
really is a lot they die like what do
you think they do with them they dig
mass graves and there is no if the body
is on Hart island yeah that's that's
that's and it's only gonna get worse and
it's gonna get yeah it's gonna be
increasingly I don't know man look
New York City's population density is
like 28,000 per square mile
people are living in smaller and smaller
houses microscopic apartments for insane
amounts of money a certain point it's
gonna it's got a snap I mean this is the
snapping point I I know yeah people
personally that have left New York
because they not come back and they're
not coming back
yeah they're they pack their stuff up
and took it with them yeah they can't
pay for their apartment anymore luckily
they have places to go but I can't
imagine this is not happening everywhere
yeah cuz New York's expensive it's not
cheap to live there foods more expensive
livings more expensive everything is
more expensive there so and you don't
necessarily make more money there either
you know what sometimes you do and you
get lucky get a good job you know and
but it's people people are going there
and they're realizing I think I think
Kovac was the dam breaking it is yeah
exactly because now people like so many
people are dying so many people have
left because of economic reasons don't
want to come back you know I'm sure a
lot of people are scared to come back
yeah the population density was so
insane that New York City apparently now
is like the worst city on the planet for
kovat Wow New York State is like the
epicenter of infections and and people
keep trying to flock into these big
cities and and and just at a certain
point you can't sustain life that
tightly
packed the crazy thing is I have friends
that are still in New York there they
send me pictures like check check out
the park here and there's people hanging
out in the park like not not just like
sporadically or by themselves but just
you know hanging out in the park like
everything's normal
you know the the mayor actually took up
all the the hoops in the basketball
courts took them off I don't know if you
guys heard about this it's because
people kept playing basketball yep and
it's like you're sweating your coffee
you know you're not coughing but you're
you know sweating all over each other
you know playing basketball basketball
it's fun but when there's a pandemic you
know maybe you shouldn't play but now
they don't have a choice it's even
outside of the pandemic these photos of
these people digging mass graves yeah
like the defense was now we do this all
time there's there's tons of masks right
yeah they could all the time that's not
a defense that makes it worse and
weirder right they actually actually
imagine this Bill DeBlasio so used to
them doing this he actually thought
people are back oh they do it all the
time right
what do you mean he's a big deal we do
it all the time for like oh yeah it's
it's it's creepy man the fact that we've
gotten to the point even beyond before
the pandemic should have been a red flag
to everybody take it take a look at
these photos man for those of listening
I can just describe them but you've got
a bunch of people walking around in the
white like hazmat suits and on both ends
it looks like of this big trench they've
dug there's just caskets stacked up they
have a ladder going down it's got to be
like what 10 feet you think maybe 12
feet 12 feet yeah at the deep part they
out at the deep part 12 feet they got a
little over that a little bobcat or
something dude that's four three four
look at that oh that's this is showing
three coffins deep Wow three coffins
deep Wow that's crazy
oh you know where you know where's that
one coffin there it looks empty I don't
know what that means
yeah that was like maybe it busted open
and yeah dude they're stacking three
coffins recons deep wow dude
welcome who old why would anyone want to
live in this place
now it's an island yeah it's not like
you could stumble upon it
yeah and that building looks pretty
abandoned yeah yeah there's trees
growing out of the top of it yeah that's
so messed up dude that's crew we can't
live like this what's what's gonna
happen in a
in a hundred years you're gonna run out
of space on the island what do you do I
mean we're like many funerals plowing
over everything yep
yeah I'm just more concrete put more
buildings yeah I you look at a map a
satellite map of the United States okay
and you see it's green right yeah you
see it's green in the East Coast then
you as you move to the Midwest you start
seeing a little brown and the Rockies
and everything like that yeah I always
thought it was like you're seeing trees
and stuff you're not it's all
developments so I was actually I've been
looking just around various areas for
like farm properties yeah and I keep I
would look I would find like a very
green area when you zoom out on
satellite when you zoom in and get
closer and closer
it's houses suburbs you just seen the
grass but everything's been ripped apart
there are some parts like the
Pennsylvania wilds that are still you
know very very forced II for long
stretches yeah for the most part man
everything's been torn up no matter
where you go in Kansas no well no
obviously as you move west it starts
getting you know further and further
parties but the east coast you know what
now here's where it gets worse I mean
have you looked at Europe it's basically
the same right no it's worse yeah New
York is way worse check us out
more coronavirus patients testing
positive again after recovery report and
here I was getting all I was feeling
better because they were saying like we
think we're nearing the peak we think
we're in a you know I think it was you
know Trampas Trump's administration said
May first we're aiming for reopening
yeah and this story comes out this is
from today people are testing positive
again after recovery like they're
getting reinfected or let me know about
this like no well months ago someone in
Japan yeah one story is like maybe it
was a false positive maybe rice negative
yeah but we talked about having multiple
phases yep you know and that could
potentially be a thing now we have now
we have more stories of people getting
reinfected so what we can either lock
down forever talking about this stuff
you know I mean and what's really scary
is if it does mutate and we make a
vaccine for the first version and by the
time we make the vaccine and start
working it into the population if it
mutates to something different will we
always just be chasing this
you know are we gonna ever beat it if
you know what we do with the flu is
we're constantly chasing right it's not
very effective it's a it's not the flu
it's different right but in that same
sense are we just gonna forever be
chasing coronavirus you know maybe maybe
we can't even maybe we've just reached
the point where humanity can't grow
larger than it is mm-hmm
there's the scary premise what do we
have like seven point where we eight
billion seven seven point something
billion maybe that's the line and then
the the the population density is so
intense the the prepend plus with
airplanes you know and and a transport
we have maybe is the point where it's
not even about the corona virus but any
virus this point could spread so fast
that we can't have you know we are
traveling everywhere even if we had less
people that really is airplanes you know
that have changed the game it's true
now here's but here you know that we're
not at Spanish flu levels right and you
know even then they had the the first
wave in the second wave and I think it's
like a third wave but even as bad as it
is right now mmm-hmm it's we're not in
you know I was like what twenty million
died of the Spanish flu right but can
you imagine if they had airplanes as
normal as it is now that's what I'm
saying like even with with airplanes
kovat is nowhere near as bad okay but
what's strange is that the Spanish flu
is mortality rate was less I think
that's why everyone's freaking out okay
they also didn't have the internet and
there was a war going on so it's a good
point we might be facing something
comparable but we're better equipped to
deal with it right so the war time a lot
of soldiers died and was it because they
strictly were healthy and got this or
were they wounded from battle already
and you know we're susceptible I was
reading about it they said that the
natural selection was inverted because
typically when people get sick they stay
home okay makes it harder to spread make
sense but with the war people who got
sick worse were sent back on trains to
go home and so it spread everything
everywhere you know a lot worse but it
but it did come in in a couple waves so
it was like in August it came back
really strong and started hitting
younger people I believe or I think it
start hitting younger people the second
wave I don't know what's gonna happen
with the with kovat I can't tell you I'm
bored and it's frustrating I mean we're
lucky enough to have a house in the
backyard
and some you know open space but I can't
imagine these these people are gonna get
restless New York City is gonna be a
nightmare
uh what kind of already is it's kind of
a time bomb yeah so so these stories I'm
saying like in South Jersey they
arrested a bunch of people for walking
around outside seriously yeah it was it
was a couple people were like seen
leaving a house and someone called the
cops on him the cops rolled up and said
you guys need to go home and then
apparently one of them said after you I
don't need to do anything so the cops
were like you're under arrest
yeah yep like why though they said
they're obstructing government something
no I mean yeah okay why that why would
they arrest them but why would you just
say that to the cop who's just doing his
job
it's America feels a little First
Amendment yeah sure can't get arrested
for it but apparently they'll make it up
yeah that is that not common knowledge
now it's like well what do you know if
you just work and the knee and just say
yes I'm sorry my leash or do you I mean
I go after stuff I can do whatever I
want
sure I don't know I mean I went for a
walk today I came to me and was like go
back home you're not allowed out I'd be
like okay I would say okay my my homes
that way even though it's that way and I
go around lock it could finish my walk
like how are they gonna know you know
it's like well like what if the cops
pulled up they're like hey turn around
and go home right now okay okay you turn
around yeah whatever I can still turn
the block and keep walking in different
directions what they're following you
okay if they're following probably this
stuff happens all the time in Chicago
sure I'd probably walk on it and I've
had cops follow me to my house and
they'd wait and say go inside because
Chicago has curfew for people under 18
and so so those if you're luckiest they
do if you're unlucky they pick you up
and then they they bring you you know if
they can't get to your house then they I
don't know exactly what they do in
Chicago because every time it's happened
to me one time I had some they bring me
home and then someone it's a sign for
you for breaking curfew she's yeah if
you're a minor in Chicago there's curfew
that's ridiculous
yeah I agree that's pretty crazy but I
mean I would go out and skate in the
middle tonight but like what do you do I
mean that I'm a you know I was a
teenager so it's like whatever but today
I don't explain myself to anybody yeah
if I'm going to the grocery store I'm
one of the worst restarts on your
business bug off and then what they're
gonna arrest you that's apparently what
they did someone mouthed off so they
arrested him yeah I mean look that's
stupid to mouth off to people at the
same time your your that's not illegal
you're right I agree with you yeah dude
we're in it man yeah and the nightmares
topia is so boring it's frustrating you
know yeah can't we at least have like
some kind of la resistance like a real
one not like these weird scrawny loti
college kids who think they're fighting
you know Nazis like an actual and
you know like you want some action go to
New York and you get to New York and
there's just nothing there yeah it's
just the streets are empty it's the it's
the romantic their mental Romanticism
the apocalypse yeah it just doesn't
exist yeah there is no life is not here
yeah it's either boring or it's
stressful that's that's why I think
people think they're gonna be like on a
roller coaster yeah I think the only
thing that would cause this kind of
post-apocalypse we usually think of is
something like someone attacking us on
our shores which we've already
established is not gonna happen
I don't know I don't think so you don't
think so having actually been in places
where there explosions and people
shooting at each other there's this
feeling you get watching these action
movies where you see like the hero do a
backflip you know and like land
perfectly and then do it like roundhouse
kick the bad guy who then falls into the
meat grinder eat it doesn't exist yeah
that feeling you get watching his movies
doesn't exist yeah the excitement of
watching the guy you know draw the bow
and fire at the zombies head and this
head explodes in slow motion yeah it
doesn't exist I'll tell you what you
really get you get anxiety and panic
attacks right you're standing there and
then all of a sudden you're shaking and
you're like about to throw up because
your stomach's clenching because there's
people screaming and stabbing each other
and you haven't eaten in a while and
you're right there's yeah some people's
not going to be people landing on our
shores it's gonna be other citizens that
are hungry that want your food
well no no like in the event let's say
like someone did land on our shores like
an invading force okay all these people
who are like meh to be so cool look you
know like Red Dawn or whatever they they
would they would it would be five
minutes until their buddies had got
blown off where they'd be sobbing in the
corner crying begging for how the world
used to be
thanks for check
this clip from the tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live monday through
friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you